all right and I am live flashpoint eat
bot s what's going on man oh you know
just another Friday morning gotta work
got in and got my butt whooped had to
shower and clean them bad for that well
this isn't just like hey let's change
clothes and start the podcast no no
hey I sweat more than most people in an
issue to deal with but sweaty morning so
I had to just go on but feeling nice and
clean and squeaky squeaky clean job so I
got that in arm D gotta get the guns bro
get that Cohen gang but oh yeah was a
good one man came back some like alright
it's our time to talk about this thing
of us it's flat pointment
lot going on a lot to talk about oh my
gosh your question on what you what
you've been doing in destiny this week
and I tell you it up again uh well been
practicing and I'll save my question a
little bit later but working on couple
solo guides I was kind of debating on I
did a warlock solo run on whisper I did
it on say like Monday morning I always
have like a meeting at 11:00 I literally
started thinking like 10:20 and I
finished it but then when I go back and
listen to it some of the talk isn't that
great it's not like my favorite video
but I was like I know it's doable but I
was just working on heroic so the guy
had stuff like that
but honestly just been going through
like my buddies jumped in on Tuesday so
we went through like as many of the we
did the mission again we did just kind
of your basic weekly resets you know
working through a gambit crucible
working on the flash point which is
mercury shoot me in the face oh my god
okay seriously I'm honestly like I'm
gonna say already why in the world in
mercury what did they take away the the
majors as counting for the damn flash
point x tilde stop that
yeah I'm which man I I it was plenty
doing that flash point this week I was
very bored I very discussed it and then
like you said I
even realize it until like maybe I was
shooting majors for about maybe 15-20
minutes running around and I'm sitting
in like let me check my progress and I'm
like whoa I'm not doing anything like I
just wasted so you're like naughty when
she do heroic adventures you know and
then we all know that damn public event
don'ts on nearly enough no have that
thing up like every 10 minutes why not
make that place interactive there's no
reason but honestly there's one thing
for every flashpoint ever controls
should count yes no reason this should
not if I breach percent if I do 20
patrols I think I put in some time on
that planet
mmm-hmm preach that is another missed
opportunity it makes it that's why I
have much other purpose you ain't will
throw them in their backs there's
nothing else to do on this planet but
patrols around thank God I got the
Sakura show that I'm looking for
simulation seed and all that but yeah
I'm which mercury is such a
disappointment it hurts my soul on that
legs you know how I feel about Osiris
you know how I feel about the law and
I'm just this damn you know parking lot
that we got to go to oh no it's that man
Oh UK dad's and Pete what's going on
yeah he's welcome to chat with misty the
discussion yeah man that's pretty much
it but for me um this week has been very
interesting a lot of gambit praying a
lot a bit getting a lot of I mean
actually getting really how do you see
him the meatball nope never seen its in
what's up it's gonna be the worst week
to try and see it for now I've heard
I've heard bad days since didn't see
what's going on um yeah so I did a lot
of gambit um really enjoying that I got
like a nice little gambit bill and it
gave me weapons all really nice like I
really like that that auto has it at a
cast I got trust the hand can't sick
roll oh my oh my baby though it's
bygones you got bygones yet no have not
got one never got one
gibbet pretty good amount like I mean I
haven't hit in for me but I'm like I
don't know five six thousand
I lose a fair amount so do the math it's
probably a chunk yeah no I've got what
have I actually got from gambit besides
a whole bunch of trash I even got the
full set so I can get the powerful gift
see that armor I feel like I've got like
if I played my Titan I've got a full set
there warlock I've been picking up into
more it's funny I've been working on my
Titan more then I started leveling up my
warlock yeah and then I did the raid on
him he blew past my Titan form the
warlocks at 575 I jumped past him I did
get one bad omens with tracking but
unfortunately also got Genesis so no
tracking you know what's funny
I still wasn't there I still don't
really know like confession I still
don't really know what Genesis does like
someone I'm waiting for like fallout to
do a video hey like I should probably
break that perk down because that was
like in theory it says breaking the
combat shield with this weapon refills
its magazine from its reserves so say a
rocket has one bullet the magazine and
if I hit granted it's gonna have to be
something big to break the shield and
not kill it but say I hit a Minotaur
major with a void rocket launcher and a
vogue shield if I break that shield then
hopefully it sounds like it's gonna pop
another bullet into that clip so you
could fire again I guess if you break
the shield then you can keep going same
thing if you broke a shield with a auto
rifle then you could literally just keep
firing and put the damage out because
now you've dropped the shield no energy
weapons regenerate ammo on hit win
matching damage type with a combatant
shield so energy weapons like auto
rifles or something like that for
example sound the same so I probably I
mean I honestly haven't seen much out
there on it I don't know if it's like an
amazing perk I guess it depends I think
something where it might almost see more
benefit to it might be somewhere in that
mid range like scout or pulse
yes and it might have because getting
some bullets back in the chamber there
if you'd like hey pull you like three or
four trigger pulls just a lot of a
shield and then you get a full clip to
work them down then you can be a little
more efficient taking that guy out
without a reload guessing but sounds
like I meant yeah I'm with you it's like
I haven't seen much on Genesis on that
perk at all yes
yeah it's not really explaining well so
you're pretty much there and then
low-key I've been knocking out all my
powerful gear but uh low-key I've been
playing a ton of crucible man I'm a
beast with the void lock the what is it
to minna fission I'm a beast or yeah
I'll do it is the most dominant class
for crucible as a warlock
you get schooled in that cuz I have
tried that once or twice and I suck I'm
gonna be honest is not trust me it's we
cuz I actually had this come straight
out the dizzy you had this conversation
he's like I love whatever you know the
comic ami Han I'm like listen that's
cute I get seven pieces kinda frequently
nothing thing do did you see my video I
put up like what a tweet I put up over
seven piece as actually citizen a
gesture was with me sinister was with me
yeah I got a seven piece with him and
then it got like he said handheld Nova
that is insane also cool guy has a video
up right now with um your minions that
um is that there's a warlock exotic for
the arms I forgot basically what it does
is you know how to warlock charges
grenaded holds it mmm what to create the
supernova or create like devourer and
all that stuff with this exactly you
hold it and then you can tank damage
like forty percent less damage like you
can take more damage hold yes actually I
didn't even know oh I'm so jelly I don't
want damage charging Marika resist
incoming damage while charging your void
grenade with chaos accelerant feed the
void or handheld supernova charging boy
grenades return at random mode of
grenade energy on hit though but also
that game will kick your butt so hard I
was going to be original our game shout
out to Dad's on our um yeah I've been
rocking with that and I've basically
I've started I'm very far in my
rhetorics grind I'm very far so I've
been doing a lot of hmm
solo offline play
like I said I just really love crucible
so much especially with the Nova
especially with the lineup I got right
now I think I'm rocking on bygones
escalation protocol should shotgun
because escalation protocol shotgun does
not move out of my energy slap and home
heavy I go between or cliffs I'm giving
you our secret so now go back to your
war cliff or I go I got a LLL play at a
game with rampage and some other crazy
perk and I think I got a mod in it that
gives me an extra magazine yeah yeah
it's nasty it's play of the game
forsaken dropping or is it just like an
older one oh no no it's forsaken trust
with random role I haven't seen one yeah
I got my edge friends it's 1 2 3 17 18
19 20 hold on go to hundred you 23 24 25
26 27 28 29 30
I haven't deleted that many of them just
more sheer entertainment value 30 edge
transits that is nuts that's crazy but I
mean we'll cover a piece as well but
it's like there's just not that many
options in the heavy slot light now I'm
like yeah that's got one thing I'm
noticing with random roles like we got
random roles but man we got random on
like 10 guns
10 guys here but heavies you're right
having been lacking yeah you're right so
yes pretty much it now just been
grinding now I'm doing real good I went
to the super kills part about to blaze
that out oh and last I'm gonna tell you
real quick yo finally I got a cat I got
a crucible catalyst I could not believe
it
guess which one uh I'm trying to think
what the crystal ones are too I got Jade
rabbit recently I don't know is that one
of them I got Jade rabbit recently but
that's what the oh I can't think what is
it what'd you do I got vigilance full
disclosure remember before they said you
had to win a crucible match to get it I
won the mess but it dropped in mid match
while yeah while we were winning but I
thought the criteria was like after the
match I don't know when they dropped mid
match and we were really slaughtering
but yeah so I got unlocked to follow the
problem is is like it's like you're
gonna
yeah it's like here you go but business
is good but um I don't know how it it's
not as dominant in as it was it's still
viable but I can feel the difference but
I want to see once I unlock full auto
how that goes but that's me yeah yeah
it's like for me I got I gotta go figure
with outlaw and rampage so and it's got
a nice work on it so if that's not
pretty much the role I'm gonna want on
that one I don't know what else to ask
for Oh
specially in PvE beasts in with that but
I will honestly say one that I did not
expect to like as much as I did and I
want another perk to go with with it
triple tap one tiger spike triple tap on
an auto rifle do thanks it's like what I
got not see that actually being as good
as it is yes I got the curated um Auto
flow rate Oh
I've not seen that it's called like
age-old something do it's got that new
perk four times a charm
which is basically triple tap well
double type thing yeah almost double
from well rats and she typing plus um it
got rampaging on it and it's master work
10/10 tier already mmm thanks here I was
forget to take ten here to get the or
the orbs the drop yes
yeah I got the highlight oath the sniper
from dreaming city is it your ten drop
so that one comes with snaps lights in
box breathing so nice yeah the weirdest
thing I actually got two of those
literally at the same way like 30
minutes that's what the whole duplicates
like bug because sometimes but still
definitely happens it was like I went on
one character turn him a dreaming City
bounties because it was like early in
the morning before I went to work before
he said you know me dreaming city
bounties on one character switch over
the other one tournament I literally got
it on both I was like are you kidding
it's fine like I just don't need two of
them like yeah exactly
probably break it down and see how many
master old course you get from one of
them at this point but it's just weird
nah fee so let's get into this thing man
we got some to talk about you know
things going on
ah so good old bungee definitely
stepping out there saying it's been a
bit we've had three weeks or so we made
full circle and we've got some things to
talk about but raids have been beaten we
have you know triumphs are being earned
people are getting crazy high scores
because they've been accident as we said
god rules are dropping that we're
getting you know people finishing gear
sets a couple people have been getting
titles not that raid one yet which by
the way is a beast title but know what
else that's gonna take the finish finish
it but right now I was like their God
yeah yeah guys I don't think I'm never
gonna do that one oh that's that's a
crazy group so all that stuff's going on
they have more coming but they have some
changes coming during October some of
which I wish were like tomorrow but we
gotta wait a little longer for those but
yeah Lots going on I know you've been
playing a lot I've been playing a lot so
let's see just kind of what they're
working on first and first piece we got
the meatballs probably like somebody's
horror movie yeah it looks crazy yeah
it's kind of late I they call this thing
be ascendant primeval servitor the fact
that this is even remotely a servitor
looks like basically like a server that
got taken over by aliens conservators
are so like technological and fallen and
they look like a machine and this thing
literally looks like a meatball like a
feeling in face so they're a meatball or
the other one I'll keep it clean
another part of someone's Anatomy yeah
yeah the thing is so this is a thing
that you have to shoot in the face it's
the malfeasance quest to start now one
thing people are saying and I heard it
on different podcasts in places that
people are going like 10 20 30 80
matches and this thing is not showing up
crazy
there's some weird glitches that come
along with this one you have to actually
kill this thing when it actually drops
like it goes for both people but you
have to be the team to drop it so for
one you know you're screwing somebody
over what if you see a pop-up and then
the other team just as the whole you
know you're you're against a team before
and they just melt them you're like welp
there that goes so
there are a lot of issues with this
right now and people just want to start
a quest and it's like the whole RNG
nature too it makes it difficult yes so
there are some tweaks come in for gambit
for you guys that are still playing it
not sticking through it if your solo
like me I feel the struggles I feel the
pain believe me you can either you know
hate him or join him with the sleeper
party but either way honestly one of
those if you don't see sleeper in a
match I just looked like the match feels
pretty good like sometimes I'll get
sniped we'll be like hey damn good shot
with a real sniper rifle right I'll go
over get a couple pole shots you know
maybe do my missile whatever you're
gonna do it feels good and then as soon
as you see sleeper in there just like
eff this like I mean it just kind of
honestly gives me a little jab in the
side basically so you have the opposite
field ways I look forward to invaders
because I've literally sleeper in one
using it because in turn when if I go
and invade and like they're like oh I
look in two spots and I snipe you across
the map then I have no chance to
actually put that invasion to use but if
I'm not using that so I mean if somebody
hits me with whisper from across the
mouth because for one that thing's a my
sister's real low and I'm like hey damn
nice shot if you like if you hit me with
sleep rebel like hey you can aim near a
giant barn door and still hit the damn
thing so it's like can you hit the
broadside of a barn with sleeper yes but
everything else no no you're right yeah
definitely I'm finished I just wanna
shout out in brings 99 in chat he's
talking about gambit you say this is a
huge issue
I went from mythic one all the way to
reset my infamy and still have not seen
the Beast of what you call it the uh
what was that enemy from Alfie so you
get the malfeasance there that so-called
taking the sending servitor yeah sorry
guys
in my chat as well I think I had my
desktop audio loss I think I've got you
fixed now I'll just make sure I just
that when it comes to uploading the
video so let me go in chat if he's good
I was recording game stuff and forgot to
adjust but yeah a couple glitches I've
seen one that I really heard that was
probably the worst troll of all um
basically I heard somebody invaded saw
the meatball head spawned and then
literally they quit out of the match
what if they could not finish it they
literally just host them Wow Wow that's
probably the worst thing I've heard on
that when I was like wow so they did it
what he knew he was gonna lose already
or they just did it off top I don't know
if they just did it just to piss him off
or what but I heard that nose like wow
that's a brutal brutal troll like I mean
if they quit and for some reason because
I think if everybody leaves it just goes
to the end you kind of finish the match
because I feel like it happened once if
it was down low and like people quit out
but honestly I heard that was like how's
that even like a thing yeah real trollee
so yeah I think they I think we were
getting to the 12 they're gonna mention
about maybe enabling sometime I'll quit
and quit of here because I didn't
realize there was no penalty enabled as
of right now yes they've been like they
had some issues with it before so they
took it off for a while I think they
tried to bring it back there are some
issues again they put out on Twitter
yesterday that's back off so they keep
having issues of quitter penalties but I
mean honestly if you get you know on
quitter penalties go do something else
there's so much stuff to do in this game
take a breather like yes I mean if you
get disconnected is one thing they said
they're trying not to do multiple I'll
get to it but yeah the quarter penalties
are definitely something to talk about
so we'll kind of get to it later
the whole three weaker cycle I want to
get to that in a different piece but
when the curse is at its strongest
basically we just finished up with a low
piece of the curse and then it kind of
progresses over a three week cycle when
it is the strongest they're going to
work on changing the spawn rate of the
meatball so basically they say it's
gonna be almost as often as any other
boss so whether it's the Minotaur the
you know phalanx whatever it is is a big
one that you're fighting hopefully when
it is every third week when the curse is
that the absolutes
youngest they're actually gonna make it
just about an even rotation through the
bosses which i think is good which will
give people a lot of opportunities to
get it they did say they're gonna buff
the other two weeks but it just won't be
quite as often but I mean it sounds like
that was a must I know they wanted to
make it kind of rare but the fact that
you have to kill the boss you actually
have to see it's fun and then there's a
lot of variety and gambit matches are
not slow they're like 20 minutes if they
don't they don't run quick you know if
you go if you especially you fight back
for one and then still lose well you're
like well that wasn't it so yeah the
fact they take a little while and I mean
not everybody has that much time to even
start the thing much let's do it's not
the shortest quest I remember looking
through all the steps of it there's
pieces to it so working on that and then
because they're going to increase the
spawn rate of the boss they basically
said when you kill the boss and seems
like that's when your quest is gonna
start rather they said on subsequent
boss kills anything that you anytime you
see that boss and killed in the future
the vanity items be a ghost or sparrow
or one that generally were kind of a
guaranteed drop when you got it right
now they said they're gonna make those a
chance because the boss is gonna spawn
more frequently which to me is fine
cosmetic sir you know a chance that's
fine yeah I'm cool with that I'm cool
with that
yeah so the Court of Protection said
they are developing a changed again but
matchmaking will extend the load times
some players have been experiencing or
at least helped with the extended load
times when the change is released I'll
be re-enabling the quitter penalties for
game but playlists whether you increase
the number of games players can leave
before they're restricted from the
playlist so maybe if you leave I don't
know how many that numbers I wish they
would just say yeah as opposed to we're
going to increase the number it's like
transport and say hey the next part
literally ammo credit changes too and
this stuff like detail obviously they
will increase the number of games it's
very very the numbers sometimes they
that'd be a finite can have the exact
amount of experience I need on my
experience bar please o member that
they've got better than sometimes
they're still they gotta gave me
questions
basically they're just trying to
mitigate some of the situations or bad
internet if it drops you you're not
screwed out of a game mode and it's like
one of those work you know try and take
some stuff into effect if you get kicked
out for a second and it's a quick drop
and then you come back in well like you
know wait two minutes or something
people be in the game for 20 minutes
anyway but like you know if you drop two
in a row well take an hour I don't know
like and I'm not one of the ones to test
and make those decisions because I am
NOT a game developer never will be but
yeah it's just kind of one of those
pieces it's it sucks to come into a
match either part way and yeah
understood and honestly the piece that
takes me off the most is when someone
leaves just the fact that you're down
for even like a minute that minute is
crucial so oh yeah absolutely see burn
it out yes when they drop if it's early
on and you're trying to gather motes and
they're just able to kill them and
gather them faster deficits so fast if
you're not with flight I lose a whole
set of for its bird absolutely mm-hmm
I feel like I've been talking a lot so
feel free to jump in now I'm waiting for
that we are we have the power crate
because that's where I'm at
that's why yeah okay so I'm ready for ya
power ammo crate changes so to help
balance some weapons we're changing the
amount of a Melchor see when opening an
ammo crate mostly they're talking about
heavies to big ones
sleeper simulant okay will change to two
shots down from four and swords ammo
crates will grant twelve up from six is
dang it had to happen yeah I know I'm
team sleeper yeah I know this ya know
I've been telling people about the
sleeper since d1 sleeper was my baby
before galley I didn't I was the sleeper
guy so obviously we know it's it's
running its reign of terror right now we
have the sleeper meta let's keep it a
buck you know as far as gambit and it's
funny you know sailor I do hear you guys
points I'm just laughing because it's
like finally happened for a weapon that
I like tickets cattle hilarious but
obviously we know some changes got to be
made you know the first one they said is
gonna be with the last while they talked
about the Amos s value right come
together with it right so you have that
now in conjunction with the ammo crate
only granting two shots down from four
significant because at the end of the
day you know you don't want people
running around with a thousand you know
cuz look you can really be savage just
so ya know like if you're if you're
running linear fusion reserve perks and
on your armor and if you're running
leading linear fusion scavenger do I can
have up to eighteen to twenty eight
sleeper shots see that is just nuts yeah
like you can you can do the most I run I
can get cuz I like to I don't like to
have all reserves I like to have
scavenger because scat see this is gonna
be the key that's what I'm talking about
this having a scavenger perk sometimes I
can randomly pick up a power brick and
get anywhere between three like from
four to six bricks per pickup yeah I
suppose to now them saying to so the key
will be will this effect scavenger I say
no I think they won't I think that if
you don't have any of the perks it's
just gonna be a default to instead of
the fall which is fine but the key will
be does this affect the scavenger perks
will those get effect and then obviously
the second thing which is swords which I
really want to talk about this is good
because you know ammo crate will grant
12 sword ammo up from six this is a huge
thing because swords in my opinion since
D to launch have been woefully under
used like yeah especially in PB I've
seen PvP guys use them once in a while
but in PvE its yeah it's not there so
this is a good this actually creates
investments in swords I'm have to dust
my arm what is it it's they're back from
the raid that that's that off and um you
know it would be good to see how that
plays out kind of like China meltdown
Prime Evils and stuff in gambit but I
like that cuz like I said swords really
needed love they didn't they weren't
used and they were really beasts in d1
so what do you think about both of these
like sleeper change in the sword change
was your side on it
I mean sleeper is good mm-hm it's one of
those two where I know there are
different ways to burn down bosses I've
seen I mean if you go we had multiple
people with like shotguns a well of
radiance and
you even did the damn said no shield if
you put all three of those together I
mean you have a coordinated team that
can do that oh yeah who's in two of
those in two you know I closed shotguns
or something absolutely annihilate box
mmm but what sleeper can do from a range
with an aim assist with you want
shouting at oh and still killing you
from the map right I mean you can feel
like you're even gonna like miss
somebody's are flying across and I still
get the kill and I'm like I don't even
think I should have got that one so yeah
and I'm gonna call I got a snipe
yesterday honestly I was just nervous
was it this morning early yesterday
night mm-hmm once night and it was I was
just like how did how did that even
happen I was literally being shot the
flinch must have popped me through his
head and just like all right we're gonna
give this one to you so those moments
I'm like aw damn but I mean with the
sleeper it's like I'm generally in your
vicinity dead
so the aim-assist coming the ammo going
down to them happiness the ammo goes
down it's hopefully gonna help also like
not everybody's gonna have it like if
you're unsleep ER you can't kill the
whole team especially early on if
somebody jumps in and has sleeper then
you know that's kind of brutal now if
you come in and you face like two of
them well for you yeah that's just kind
of one of those I do like how the heavy
ammo resets every round so I'm at least
it like kind of wipes that one ounce
you're not just saving because then
everyone would just have 20 of them but
no I'm good with both of these and
swords like I don't use them that often
because for one they don't feel that
strong the ammo hasn't been there so I'd
be okay if this was even up to like 15
because really if you're gonna do it for
the PvP piece of this you would it
wouldn't if you can get that close you
know more power to you but we're just
killing ads and things like that
I mean it's heavy but I can go kill
quite a few ads with you know most
heavies anyway so just the fact that I
can get a few more swipes on down like
100% on board with both of these so yeah
they needed to happen on both sides
yeah no objections really I'm just
trying to think like we'll see how
sleeper does if the aim assist is a
little lower if it still can body shot
your toe if you still look at them you
did so body shot it's like you don't
have to be that close to anything any
vital organs like and they're done
I'm gonna know a big laser beam but like
you know I'm a guardian I might still be
able to work if my shin gets burned but
if you like you blow my leg off that's
fine like singed my leg hair then I
don't think so
I'm not gonna take this leap with
disrespect are you helpy that gun is
that's fine
but take that gun away and tell me you
don't have a more balanced match across
the entire board you gotta let me have
this moment it's the first matter I've
ever had we good
so this is gonna run down so hopefully
quarter penalty's they've got a couple
dates for patches we'll get to those in
a little bit and hopefully more often
this boss will be spawning so if you
don't have malfeasance don't break your
neck over it if you see the boss and it
goes just know in a few weeks you'll be
able to see this thing more frequently
which for everybody should be a good
thing because I am not even close to
seeing this thing I haven't seen it once
so me the updated calendar we got a
couple patches coming so two point 0.4
it's gonna be on the sixteenth they've
got one thing it's actually probably a
good thing for everybody wandering out
there your ability to hover over lost
sectors and see their name once a player
has looted them so if you have actually
been to a lost sector before you'll be
able to look and see the name which is
good honestly I've been literally like
putting off doing bounty videos for like
spider to be like hey this you know this
Lots lost sectors here and this is the
boss like I feel like they would just be
a quick video but honestly it's mostly
just to explain where the loss sector is
honestly that's just like helps everyone
I think it's a good piece over all
players can track up to three pursuits
I'm alright with that so I can work on
scram so you can actually track three
which is very cool quality of life I
like that little stuff sometimes oh yeah
add that in talk to me added through the
fire and flood was an OB ad and pretty
good thing fr4 to the wool which I'm
pretty sure all heavies though edge fans
that will have some company yes transits
might get a little bit more balanced out
there yeah busted me out help me out
Zenobia D is the pulse or Auto what's
their baby let me feel like I don't
remember and what's fun I don't even
remember what stole fire and flood see
crooked thing I remember that was my
baby that was on linear precision and
that one had the crazy ring use the
rocket launcher oh oh that's what some
hockey ones I'm hockey good that's good
so fire flood might be a heavy then so
okay yeah grenade launcher must be
wonderful adaptive I'd be interested
gambit weapon I guess ya know kind
haven't seen melon and then crooked Fang
fr4 is Oh many your fusion so nice so
those would be more options to drop
which honestly thank God designer more
variety in my heavy Department because
really it's like friends that are bust
that's a good that's a good addition I
like that update yeah I mean but this is
one of those things I kind of want to
bring this topic up now feeling as we've
played I don't know how many hours do
you think you put in a forsaken I mean
it 100 at this point using minimum easy
easy easy work 100 trying to think but
do you get the feeling now that we've
slate I've seen pretty much almost
everything except say a few game at
weapons that are specific to mode but I
don't personally think just in the
general legendary pool and they started
forsaken with enough variety personally
um definite argument could be made I
think what's happening is um they're
able to get away with it because of
random role so random roles have
extended the life of the limited weapon
so to speak yeah but I would agree with
you I mean if you put a gun in my head I
would say now that we've peeled back you
know a big layer of it yeah yeah you
don't see enough guns and maybe what
they need to do is kind of what this
update is doing with this heavy slot
which is they may need to reintroduce
you know the d2 starter some of those d2
starter weapons because that was the
problem people have people like damn we
got all these good weapons now that are
gonna be out you know outclassed and
performed by these new weapons so I like
when I see crooked fraying and zenobia
because those weapons that you know I'm
saying like I was not gonna use any not
literally broke those Nana you know for
master workers and all that but um yeah
I think you you're onto something you
are correct
I think the pool is not as deep but it's
it's being masked by the ability to have
so many roles for these guns so we kind
of look over a little bit but yeah I
think you think you're actually correct
yeah it's like it for me it just feels
like a point of even if it was just
every soft and if they did a patch they
brought back like one per slot like
literally just slowly stunning d1 guns
just work on some random set rolls stuff
like that like one thing I'd love to
bring back give you mind banana with
random rolls with random rolls get it
out there in the mix like give me some
energy and give me a big boost in scouts
holy hell Scouts need some love like
it's going out of style
I know they're gonna get coming but I
still don't think even gonna be enough
let me tell you I got some Scouts right
now that I got on stash with some crazy
rolls and I'm just putting them aside
I'm not I think they might be surprised
I think they might because there's some
that are good right now but it's just
they can't compete with a pulse right
now poles and pulse basically does the
same damn thing but better yeah but
better right so it's just any shooting
with a faster time to kill so if they
make them truck which I think they're
gonna do I think they realize it they
they what nobody had a stealth nerf
initially yeah they said that and I was
like when the hell did like yeah I mean
yeah I got an a I got a couple nameless
Midnight's and I was like yes the wind
is awful now it's awful it feels
terrible so they did stuff nerf it now
you take that stuff away with now an
additional bump on it I think they're
gonna play right I think they're gonna
play right so I would say to you hold on
to those some of those guy roles I got
some sick ones too I can't wait to test
they're just chilling in my vault you
know I took your advice I've been a
little bit more conservative now I
haven't been using everything wait till
I get more cause I'm trying to stay with
the armor that is given and so on
so Fossum do a bet you want better yeah
I mean some of us just like and I don't
mind of the fact that like hey I've had
to play with different weapons and see
how different roles work and I'll get to
experience more things and be like hey
this is my house thing let me use it for
a little bit if I'm jumping into
something it's cool to see those pieces
but yeah just I think as they have a
pretty there was a decent variety you
had three full expansions a lot of
different guns in there but it like you
don't have to dump everything back in
deliver collectively pick a few every
soft and whether it's like you know
every other patch or yeah I'm gonna
assembler is coming and I'm sure there's
gonna be stuff in that but it's just
like if you do like a November fad or
like you know festival a lot of switch
will get to a little bit a little a few
extra guns in that mix as well be like
hey we've got it if you the legendary
pool good luck find him just leave it
vague like that but that'd just be cool
to have a little more in there yeah and
they used to do that in d1 cuz I
remember they used to armed stealth drop
egg sacks I don't know one time I walked
in I was like oh you know they've added
the apotheosis veil to the loop pool I
don't know where didn't tell anybody
like so they've done little things like
this in the past and I think them being
transparent is update adding the fang
adding Zenobia that's a good sign I
think we're gonna be okay yeah just yeah
sometimes Bungie is a little slow but
they will hopefully get there yeah yeah
mm-hmm so we got a bug where priming
grams would go to your postmaster
they're gonna go straight to your mm-hmm
person transmit effects to collections
thing another one come on like this is a
step in the right direction but honestly
it still bugs me the shaders kind of
still suck
I think it's destiny reddit on Twitter
and they literally like I've used
shaders less than D in all of d2 than I
really won
you you [ __ ] them you [ __ ] them
because you don't have enough of them
even though you're in the collection you
store them you still yeah a lot of them
but I don't also I can't believe they
just made it like breakdown tin I'm like
how do you not just select the number
you want to break down click and be like
how many want to do five tens
as a technique there's a tech i'ma tell
you right now they again not making
excuses for them they're definitely
hiring some database issues and identify
issues and that's why whatever they did
with that coal
the way they handled it between ever
verse and getting shaders in the wild is
it's yeah yeah it just didn't do it
right so shout out to the geeks of the
DBS out there I feel your pain I know
the game understand it but at the end of
the day it just sucks it does suck
because it should be so much easier
thing yeah that's one of those were
taxis like yep this is still broken as
you said it's like I know there's
database and coding and stuff like that
and they mean as hard as they work just
to try and put now one thing I will say
if you give it put it into the cryptarch
when they break them down let me see the
rareness of those because if I want to
go like hey I'm ringing all the green
and blue shaders and I don't even
remember what the rareness of those
things are name of them hop up the same
way I'm like why doesn't it pop up the
same way mmm that's just one of those
weird things when you go to the cryptex
you're like alright I have to like
remember the name or the color scheme of
this one I gotta go find it they're not
even in the same order it's kind of
weird and arbitrary so it's kind of one
annoying thing to a convoluted piece of
another it's like and I'm not bashing I
know the guys out there I'm sure working
on it constantly which is something as a
player I'm not bashing but is the fact
that I don't think working on it but
again priority wise I'm sure they have
other stuff too but it's just one of
those like shaders should not be one of
those things that's still for me is like
yes like I have a big sigh over it so no
we thought we'd get a bigger improvement
than the one we get yeah like breaking
down five so I'm like it can't be like
10 20 I don't like just give me a bigger
number than provided cuz when I had to
break down 250 that's way too long
transmen effects at least being able to
see those in previews good and put those
in the collections so ya get rid of
those McFly shout out a little bit of
Back to the Future love in chat he's
like are you gonna make us our video yes
I will do that one of the few apparently
that still does one of those times I'm
gonna make is er video and be like he's
actually got a forsaken exotic the hell
out freaked out the shaded colors suck
for sake they do yeah I like none of it
what's the other one that disgusts me
it's like oh oh you know which one
disgust me the iron banner shader you
know that rusted look you know I know
what you're talking about but I'm just
saying yeah I know what you are talking
okay oh okay I'm like the swag on the
shade is I get cuz look they try to keep
it you know mathematic in the beam like
you know it's all tangled shorts or you
know they going so much for the theme
but it's just like man could we get some
nice flavors so even the dream of city
wants ain't at all that they okay I feel
like dreaming city could have some
pretty cool colors like can I give you
like a glossy shiny crystalline purple
get me the give me the color of the blue
cave that you drive through when you
head towards the observatory for your
offering to the Oracle like that cave is
like so shiny and blue yes look kind of
stupid crazy sometimes like everything
seems a little like low-key and dolomite
I don't care if I shine out like a
highlighter and a crucible match let me
do it sometimes yeah just just get a
little crazy out there sometimes Bungie
I guess give us some fun stuff but also
when you go crazy make sure you give us
a black to please a very you know I'm
saying black black not this grown like
black or carbon black but just you know
what it wasn't d1 because it was almost
like black with like I'm not quite a
tiger stripe but you know what I'm
talking about
yes I know yeah everybody was dead all
because it was like dead okay I had
those mean blacks man so we have a
effect a very rare issue in game but
where the invasion portal would not
reactivate so that would suck you know
and then they're fixing issue with 1,000
voices may cause loud screeching audio
with desire or anything or jumping so
okay apparently your headphones don't
keep those too loud you might lose your
hearing that will be on the 16th so
little stuff we'll see how Scout rifles
feel that'll be a couple weeks a few
more things in the loophole which will
be good and then I think probably the
one more people are gonna hope for is
here on December 30th so end of the
month
rebalancing function atom so
distribution and dynamo perks require in
place to be near okay what that's
talking about near opposing opponents
for super energy benefits so whether
it's like a buff from other players or
things like that they're gonna work on
balancing that mmm-hmm
I mean honestly if you're like in the
same damn encounter why not I mean if
you're halfway across the map but you're
doing you're serving as a purpose then I
feel like like I don't know maybe not
all the way but definitely widen the
radius on some of those because I'm sure
if you like you gotta be like buddy bump
into basically yeah just to get that
great yeah this is this is my category
hit a 2.0 file I'm gratis this is all me
um so now we got slightly increasing
sword damage in PvE to address player
feedback we all with that are we in
agreement with that needs to happen
alright then we got a slight increasing
fusion rifle damage easy I agree with
this I like yeah cuz I was even working
on that little solo good for the first
rating he's like you can do it with that
one but I can go like shotgun unload
real fast it takes like probably four
shots just to kill the night in the
first encounter with a pretty high
fusion rifle I'm like and just the time
it takes to fire all four even with a
decent charge rate it it did not it like
don't quite match some other stuff right
now I think and I think it had to do
because every one of the first
combinations I went to run when I found
out about weapon slot changes was I
wanted to run merciless in energy and
I'm you know big you know just didn't
feel strong and I was like I think it's
one of those cases where it was maybe
stealth nerfed because of things going
to energy slot let's keep it real
bungees been known for stuff like that
some stuff definitely got a sneaky like
turn that knob down I agree then we got
increasing viability of malfeasance and
PvE and gambit activities as it should
supposed to be a powerful gun so I like
that for the exotic adjusting visibility
of the Titan banner Sheol making it
easier for players to see through the
effects I like that that's cool
adjusting exotic rewards to help reduce
the number of duplicate drops let's go
let's see this one I believe it exactly
Lizzie because I I still have not had I
don't have a forsaken exotic are you
giving not one I've got I could tell you
of course I can drops that is pearl its
I've tried not to complain but now it's
getting to know like I can absolutely
understand that so on the other side of
things
yeah now this is where RNG is like you
know Pope Bear orangey type love
situation I'm gonna list off the
forsaken exotics I have head drop talk
to me
Black Talon Wow Trinity ghoul Wow I got
Lord of wolves from the spider bound I
don't even want to talk I know I feel
like I'm not done what else did I get
I've had like I mean I've had other oh I
got armor what did I get
I got Ursa furiosa wow these are all
four seconds by the lezzy ain't
controversal that's what I want so bad
that in those boots for the wall so bad
I think that's all of them mm-hmm
that's literally every four second
that's what was like we've probably
played about the same amount of time I
don't me but I know what Saturday what I
can you know like our protocol they're
old-school on the serosa gene wood cliff
coil um what was someone else I got I
got I got I got a good choice one more
as far as I don't think I got the the
tempest crown of tempest
I've got that so again is it for me let
me be clear even though I'm complaining
themselves it's not a trait itself but
it's what exotics are dropping like they
need to tweak that algorithm so that
yeah I don't want it to be exactly like
a faded Ingram but like they the base
the way they worded it is seeing that's
what I want which is that the
percentages will go up because it's
killing me man like I so many things as
a warlock I want I want the UM the
Phoenix protocol
that allows you to do stuff in the well
I want the boots I forgot the name of
those don't I on ik whatever I've got a
name that basically ends the um you know
this it lets you top off the the
lightning super controversy is another
one I want
I've got no weapons I don't even know
what I forgot what exotic weapons the
new ones are in the game the quest of
I've got obviously I have the chaperone
obviously I have the ace of spades but
those are quest steps that are given to
you when you need the requirements just
ya know anything else shoutouts to
certified in your chat you say yeah
she's got the heart light the colony of
the huckleberry I feel you certified I'm
in the same light bump I guess you know
I mean the light bumps good I mean the
arms not bad if you get new ones not
completely at least because you get
rolls on them which that is something
your old ones won't have unless you go
pull it out of your collection you have
a chance for different roles but yeah on
the weapons I think one of those pieces
to where it's like escalation protocol
the more you do an activity you have a
better chance of getting that thing to
eventually get a new one make it work
the same way if you keep getting older
exotics that technically already part of
your collection you have a higher and
higher chance to get a new one until you
finally do and maybe reset that but at
least give that addition so at some
point you are for sure guaranteed to at
least get one new one every so often you
said you don't want it all the time but
it's like we need love not out to end
Bane's in my chat try getting a
chaperone which is a quest exotic drop
in the wild after you completed the call
wow I didn't know that's even possible
stop yeah absolutely
so yeah I was like I've got some other
older exotics so it's like one of those
for me I've had an odd number of exotics
like I got a new huckleberry I've got
two serous regimes these are older ones
I got a risk runner I got a graviton
Lance this is all stuff since for phase
before taken prospector call
I'm trying to think if there's any armor
it's like that's why it's like for me
the exotics like me I've got more force
Akins than I think most people have
which is stupid I've seen a fair share
of the old ones too but man that's the
ones where it's like if it's a quest one
it should be one and done like you get
to infuse it once yeah
certified Zin my gel like what's the
secret I must do honestly
Beecher head do carries and you're then
you're good yes Ella whisper yeah solo
whisper if you can check that bucket and
box then you're good to go
no I'm not totally joking I have no
earthly idea it's just so exotics I mean
they're definitely an issue for a lot of
people right now TAS he's got it in his
articles occasionally is still an issue
you've got that one people missing just
forsake ins it's just kind of ridiculous
to some level so well we'll see how this
change goes but again I feel like
they've said David they're gonna do
something like this before and then all
of a sudden you're just like still
doesn't feel that great so that's why I
said I'll see it when and see what
happens but after that we get a chance
for unite for unique rewards to drive
would increase will increase each time
and nightfall is completed without a
unique drop so basically they basically
applying that escalation protocol kind
of orangey which I like you know I'm
Maxwell cause as rewards for specific
spider wanted bounties and general
scrapper Bally's can we get a man in
front of congregational ease his basket
because we out here there we are here
with feeding I'm like crackin where are
these cause at least now here's one
piece of those like and I think it was
tasks as are it somebody was reading
this morning or Twitter reddit who knows
mm-hm
master requires being behind the spider
bounties means you have to go grind for
the spider bounty parts just to get the
spider bounties and then go do the spec
economy and there is a like a really
convoluted cycle there and it's like are
you like really
so occasionally if you're playing you're
like hey what's that it gives you a
reason to actually go do this grab for
bounty which is fine but honestly you
should have like a one of us of all
those bounties has it one of shacks is
bounty yes
his bounty yes all of them but one uh
duration like put it all like I mean it
takes 1717 to get one up there to full
level if I want to do one of every
weapon it's gonna take a boatload of
work so like give me more if it's one a
day if I do if I don't do you know
Zavala hmm gambit and say I get three
from those that's three it's gonna take
me a damn week just to get one oh I
agree they're totally underutilizing the
other vendors and neither biggest
tragedy now say I set it at noisy zur
zur if you're not given forsaken exotics
you could at least come with a five pack
of masterwork cores pleaser be useful I
know that your will is not sure oh but I
mean these cold yes you know cuz this is
crazy like it's to the point it's so bad
for me but it's like it is so bad I have
right now like each like maybe each
Armour say like three pieces of armor
three weapons that are ready for
infusion then I have higher piece of
gear sitting there to but my light up
but guess what I don't get about the
terrorism or I'll go to I don't get the
bounties I'll go do all requirements get
my little 10 pack of whatever that's
like shards all this other stuff but
when it comes to that it is so brutal it
really is so I am hoping you know this
is this is a like you said a baby step
in the right direction but also what you
said as far as the spider bounties and
you're still gonna need those you know
fragments and it's still a little iffy
on that part there but we'll see you
know I'm saying we'll see how how its
implemented um this one's for you
reducing the time for single shader
deletion from your inventory yeah
seriously do the singles and I'm like
I'm gonna bash my head straight through
all sometimes I know
I know there's like work being done but
sometimes
as a player and I know they feel it too
yeah like there's no way like 95% of
bungees I'm playing this game about as
much as we are which is good but again
when they turn and have that frustration
I'm sure they're sitting there good do
that they walk in the morning and they
set the Cuffy down on the database guy's
desk and be like fix the damn shaders
and like then they just walk away yeah
absolutely fly you don't want to know
how many master workers I have because
I've been hoarding them like I'm a broke
man so I've been hoarding them and I
broke down a whole bunch of stuff so I
really don't wanna make you guys angry
with my master work or any knots may not
say it I mean if you guys really want to
know I'll tell you it's a desk Rosen no
I have 4,000 shards but I have 210
master of course Oh Mike D but will you
use of course but you need to do a
stream of you utilizing course oh my god
this guy I know I'm not at 600 yet so
I'm gonna have to infuse crap anyway but
like if I get duplicates on the way up
I'm just gonna throw the like you know
if I get a 590 go figure and I'm working
on my 560 I'm not gonna take everything
up and honestly for me it's just been a
way to mess with different stuff in
different roles so okay so you on this
like once I get up to the top level I'm
like okay I've got this go figure like
that outlaw rampage all right okay okay
I got to back you up one quick sec all
right you need to tell me out of all
these weapons that you are not infusing
that you have that you by far must have
a zillion or some really strong roles
borderline gob role right now even for
those guns that when you get it at the
highlight that you're using it at you
know you mean to tell me there's nothing
in that's just madness feels good I
don't want to give this up do you what
what I'm saying is later we don't have
that big of a loop pool we just covered
that so as I work my way from say like
I've got multiple characters I've worked
my animals to max level if I get a go
figure like 598 then I'm gonna throw
that 598 go figure into my good go
figure
infuse it since I know I'm actually no
I'm efficient in that master record
apartment man what would you like what
you like are you five what 50 by now 60
uh warlock Maxis 575 Titan 564 you are
close to six there's going to come a
time now but it's like some of them
there's ones that I look like looking
and I feel like I'm close like my goal
figure is probably one of my better ones
la rampage that one's pretty solid and
it's got the range perk on it now I've
got like the devil scopes I've got long
range and then it's like kind of that
middle thing I've got extended mag or
I've got appended mag someone it's but I
think everything else on there outside
of that middle one it's pretty damn good
but it's like my Tiger spite with like
triple tap it's also got pulse modern
I'm like oh like if triple tap and
probably anything else cool I would
probably jump on that masterwork as well
oh and that one came with a
counterbalance mod as well I was like
and that just came with it my dukes that
I've got I've got I'll get like outlaw
and autoloading holster oh yeah happen
field prep so I'm like ya know it's
halfway on these guns obviously I
haven't had no Jenny's like and epic
ones I have five Tiger Speights and not
one of them is one that I'd be like yeah
I love it I think what it is Dan is in
your defense I see what you do you're
like yo I'm waiting the gun gotta be
worthy like it's got I get you it and I
think we're okay you're off the hook
because what happened to me is I'm
getting God roles I was getting god
roles at like before at like 500 so as I
have 500 even a little bit before so
what was happening I'm like man this
feels good like I have on right I've a
crucible I don't set it a guy role but
it's like a semi got rolling
it just works for me which is a figure
with um full auto and moving target and
moving target is very underrated it's
very sticky then I got a it has a what
you call it mater a missus mod on it so
if I line you up you're not getting its
sticky so I get stuff like that I've got
some outlaw rampage I got a lot of
rampage outlaw we kind of stuff and
he'll clip you know kind of combos so
they're really good you don't say it I'm
just like man I just can't you know I
just can't I can't break this down not
use this anymore so I think that's
pretty much what it sounds like you've
got a lot of you know one strong perk
and then a trash yeah like I mean I
gotta go figure with moving target and
head secret well it's like head sake
you're decent then you go watch
follow-up plays names like kind of sucks
and it's just just wicked Nath shut out
the fallout I'm glad I watched that
video I didn't see it was so trash yeah
yeah I was like oh no more hexie because
those are getting broke down yeah like
okay so poles say go figure so I'm
always going like I want range I want
that thing hitting from as far out as I
can get you'll get a rangefinder moving
target high rounds so I'll get like a
medium scope and then handling I'm like
all right now you being greedy
okay now you as hard as honestly master
work course to get hell yes I'm gonna be
greedy when I finally got but I'm not
gonna dump it into a trash items but
then I got a damn good one so with a
body's waits he waits for the best
oh but anyway and she puts up with a lot
I'm still surprised she's here but yeah
that kind of covers our master work
insanity they're the reducing and then
what the development issue for fix where
yeah this is the one with the you defeat
the ascendant primeval servitor and the
opposing team gets the kill that's
coming on like on two point 0.5 socks so
well we got man we got wishes and curses
well yeah
so scrolling on down so this is kind of
one of the pieces that I want to talk
about because it's like my brother had
an issue he kind of had a question about
it more of a casual type plate here just
thoughts on this so if you guys have
been playing forsaken consistently
you've seen that The Dreaming City has
been on a three week rotation we had the
taken curse the strongest level was last
week
the shattered throne was here then
everything this week has now reset so
there's two pieces of this topic one
we've got the rain itself which we'll
get to in a minute but I kind of want to
touch on this one first your thoughts on
this whole three week cycle situation um
there's the concept of just rotating
what specifically about it just just it
in general or just the fact that say
shattered throne like the three personal
rate activity is here every three weeks
you've got I mean just to take in like
moving stuff around different ascendant
challenges you know different levels of
infestation different or you know you
fight and blend well that's that's kind
of cool but when you get to something
like shattered throne rain kind of on a
three week rotation and what if you're
on vacation it might be six weeks till
you see breath yeah stuff what do you
feel about that that's my point
I remember the dude was in chat we had
made a comment I'm maintenance man that
kind of stuff never really bothers me it
really I think you know what also I'm
gonna put it this way I take it back to
an extent I think the reason why I'm so
chill about it is because the reward is
okay to me
it's not like oh my god now you told me
you can only get sleeper simulant on a
three-week then I might have submission
right so it all comes down to what you
can only get wish ender in there right
and I'm not I know it's not like the
best but that's like one thing it's
something I want I'm going to get it
it's not that I don't want it and not
that I think it's trash it's just that
when I saw sinister and you know shout
the Attic
guys have it and I'm cool you know it's
not world-beating to me that I might and
then on top of that I heard that it's
glitched isn't it glitched alright again
it's so much to do that I'm okay but for
the people who really want it yes I
understand I understand when you're
coming from you know if that's your
thing and you're like damn I'm out of
town this week or damn you know funeral
or whatever's going on in your life and
you're unable to do that activity yeah
absolutely
you know you put it this way the best
equivalent I can give is when they did
catalyst with faction rally right that
the literally the first week was like
III week and I had to make so basically
I there was no way I could get all three
catalyst per faction so I'm like damn I
gotta make a tough decision do I go with
you know I had to go with dead or
because I wanted graviton Lance catalyst
you know and then the second one I made
a home team decision where I should have
went and got the SunShot and did future
walk off but I ended up doing a sweet
business not because I care about sweet
business but more so because I just like
do Monica shade it's not running out so
I'm gonna alright I'll just do it for
this but the reality is yes that sucked
because it was a limited time thing I
didn't I had something in my personal
life going on that I couldn't get it but
um I think you know I got the adequate
in charge there's a whole week though
you're gonna get any playing time that
that's another argument in my favorite
too because at least with the faction
stuff it was three three weeks and then
that was it
this is always the case so but listen I
understand your side man I understand
your side if you got a life and for
whatever reason that week you know your
life it keeps you you have stuff going
on always that for real I guess you know
but I did that kind of stuff really cuz
I make it my business to try to plan
that thing out if it's something I
really want like right now I know I'm
talking for a long time but the last
point I'll make is sleeper simulant
catalyst that is something I want very
bad similar I'll tell you right so right
now this week is critical for me all
I've been doing
escalation protocol because another
beginneth and I've been playing imbecile
yet I forgot I forgot I was doing that
Scalise I forgot to sneak that in so
last week was I got the the sniper so
now get the shot in a sniper this week
only thing that can drop is the SMG I am
every day I try you know I'm saying some
time in there this week cuz honestly I
don't have any of them I got the shotgun
finally I got the shotgun last week
finally so long overdue now did you
notice by the way since you've been in
there when you hit seven and I want to
know if this is something you noticed
but I feel like they never announced it
so if you finished seven kill the boss
then you can actually reactivated yeah
Rebecca six go right back to six that is
they did yes it's a great thing because
honestly it's older content and lets you
farm it because yes I don't have the
weapon you need a farmer for stuff than
this cool like that's one of those
things I wish they would announce
because that was actually a really
really smart thing if you're like hey
you went through all five six seven
levels yeah and you get you didn't get
your drop from the boss all that news
and let's just sit there and form that
thing over and over and over and that's
like a smart fix and they tell anybody
and I'm just like I see people farming
this thing and they keep starting 6 I'm
like what is happening right now and
then I noticed the little thing in the
bottom corner it's like the I can't
remember what it says that something is
still strong or whatever it is like yes
and it says it down there you can just
pop it back up again I was like that's
amazing
no that's great helps the farm be a lot
more reasonable but that's one of those
I'm like ok so that's one of those kind
of makes me wonder timeframe wise when
it comes to you think shattered throne
like if they eventually it simple and be
like are we ever gonna break it out of
the three-week cycle it is always gonna
be awfully but on the other side like
the ones who missed their subclass well
that's another piece you missed that on
three weeks then you're like that one
kind the subclass part I you can't still
get this we can you yeah no no but
correct me if I'm wrong
I thought the subclass you can get just
by doing the callee fight in the rain
you can do it by the caliphate limited
to shed it up I know but I'm just saying
like it's either three weeks of the rain
you put those two in front of a casual
person they're like well I could be
screwed either way for a couple of weeks
I'm saying I'm taking like I'm literally
full about the cash
no and that's this is why I'm literally
saying this cuz I'm the same way like I
would play like hell it's like I got
mine I'm totally good like I spent my
time in there I wanted to do it
but it was like and that's why I was
like and this is where the balancing
comes in and I'm just literally playing
from the other side right now because
you listen to like fire team chat the
same way you had somebody like Fran
versus Destin and they were going back
and forth and like they were just kind
of having fun banter but it's it's a
different perspective from somebody who
like you and I it's like every waking
moment that I can probably sit down and
play or lose some sleep over I'm
probably gonna do it on the other end
though it's like some people with like
kids or whatever it's like even just
getting three people together much less
six on those weeks like okay so if
somebody's like hey I can look forward
to a three person raid but I don't have
six people but then they miss a week
it's just there are certain pieces to it
and again I don't mind the lore behind
it I actually like the fact that they
have an explanation to it but it's just
there are for certain people that this
is going to be it's just gonna be a
tough spot and I can I can see some
frustration so that's why I was on say
if you are frustrated and I feel you
believe me and it's just one of those
pieces that I'm hope and this is the
other piece I guess as well for somebody
say Call of Duty comes out in one week
right now if you put Call of Duty
against some other people who are like
kind of jumping back into destiny but
then they play other things you're gonna
lose them quicker when there's other
stuff blowing them away and that's a
piece where if you want to keep your
player base still active as much as
possible that's wrong that argument how
quickly we forget d2 lots and I'm
noticing a lot of hardcore guys not
blaming you I'm just talking about some
of the community at all you know I'm
starting to hear this we need to make it
more accessible talk and listen look
it's okay if you miss something that
that's the thing about destiny people
have to understand you're with the way
the game is structured right now with
all the powerful game with all the loot
Masdar drops the all the the quests all
the secrets right this legit unless you
are no lifing destiny and you have
no job no responsibilities no family
right if you are no lifing you can get
600 in all three characters and all that
god bless you right but the reality is
you know you're not so the thing comes
down to is you have to make decisions
you have to make decisions in destiny
what is most important to you what is
the thing that I want the most and then
you kind of focus it now in your
argument where you are right with this
chatot throne I'm sorry can you repeat
that this chatot throne you are right in
this sense that that one is on a
rotating schedule if for whatever reason
that week you missed you missed however
I am right that it's not impossible like
every third week you always out of tune
every third week somewhat keeping the
player base around in this game has been
an issue during d2 people have issues
with her I am out there still kind of
touchy there's a lot of great stuff
going on in this game and it's honestly
amazing but for some people that like
who you know blow through the story
don't care about Laura's much they're
not quite as attached if they feel like
they have to wait for three weeks for
something like well crap like and then
something else pulls them away it's
harder to pull some back if they're like
well is it the right week I don't know
did I miss again in and it's sometimes
just the point where it's like in its
and I said I don't want it to be a
giveaway I love how the rate is hard and
honestly for me we've talked about it
before I wish when you got to about 580
you had to do the rain because honestly
20 points wouldn't stop you it was raid
or shattered thrown but the point where
shadow thrown I'd like to see more
frequently if it was that level but
there are it's just for the player base
trying to keep him active trying to keep
him going in and that's why I was like
it's just kind of one of those balances
of trying not to lose people and I know
the diehards are gonna get there every
time but it's alright there are certain
piece of the story could go both ways
and it's like I feel you we're good
we're kind of like you can ascend I know
so just one last point to that and then
I'll be done with it we don't we both we
both agree with each other the thing I
would say to those people what with the
activity player based argument
it's like that portion of that pursuit
to me is not critical it's a it's a it's
a want to have you know it's something
that's nice to have you know saying like
I don't feel it's critical like like
it's completely you're locked out of
content you know I'm saying kind of
that's just my opinion of it you know
saying um you know listen is one of
those things where destiny I think we
all talked about wanting secrets right
wanting mystery right we talked about
that Wendy to launch we didn't have
these things and now here comes dream in
city and now you got this city right
you've got this and then that third week
and you know they see the taken things
falling from the ceiling it is just
aesthetically pleasing you know I'm
saying that kind of thing I think it's a
little secrets every now and yeah I mean
long as they don't go too crazy with it
you know I'm saying having multiple
things behind time gated specific
activities you know I think it's cool
you know
in in in in my own defense I'm in the
same boat with escalation protocol I've
been wanting all those weapons for the
longest you know I'm saying in you know
one time I do it I'm like oh damn this
is the week it's not the shotgun you
know many times I played it and I'm like
this is the week it's not the shotgun
you know so done that yeah you know I've
been there man yeah you know you want it
but you get it you will get it
eventually you will get it eventually it
just comes down to you know people
really wanting it very badly at the very
beginning that's what I think yeah yeah
so I mean I think we agree there's both
sides of that argument like you see both
of them just kind of depends on your
play time and stuff like that for fur I
guess for me it's just like shattered
throne is on it and I didn't even finish
the thing I got to the over and got my
butt whooped did you finish it or no I
did not because literally I had when
they told me about it I had like a
doctor's appointment site that day and
then I didn't realize how long this
thing was and I'm like pissed so I was
able to get a replacement for me when I
left shut up Dino King and so that was
or adequate sin
Oh looking for everybody I like I've I
said yourself what was it was he good
good but yeah so I mean that kind of
covers that one it's just one of those
it's such an awesome experience though
from what I even got to play and I
didn't finish it I just want everybody
to be able to jump in there cuz it is so
cool yeah yeah it's just like an amazing
piece and I just want as many people to
see that as possible because I didn't
even expect I was like hey I don't even
know how big it is we start exploring
I'm like holy crap this place is huge
so just so many pieces I didn't expect
so very very very cool content so it's
been kind of awesome so just like more
people seeing it the better it's just
one more piece that we had no idea
coming and it took three weeks to get
here so absolutely absolutely and then
the other side of this very long-winded
discussion the last wish raid
now I haven't have I have not fit have
you killed Riven yet I have not no I got
two more goth and then the group we were
doing just couldn't put it together
I've seen people like one pays that guy
so I definitely know it can be done we
just didn't have a very focused group
but honestly when I jumped in I was like
hey I'll be happy killing Kali and this
is for me where it's like this is coming
from the world of world oh the world of
world of warcraft that's a redundant
statement coming from wow it's I've been
through that like it takes like a long
time to progress through her aid because
you have to build up getting more and
more pieces as you go and actually like
how that feels and for me that was like
me I'm probably gonna sound like the
elitist now be like honestly it'd be
cool if like if you could not get to 600
without doing the raid because that
would actually that was one of the
pieces for me that made Balter glass so
damn popular because you had to do it
right people were on lfg more people out
there willing to do what more people
were actually decent like Sherpas and
stuff like that because like everybody
had to do it you could not get max level
without it right so but if you weren't
max level the world that nin crucible
still liked pretty much across the board
the same if you were say couldn't hit
any higher than 580 what if it was even
like 585 15 levels
big of a difference and say iron banners
about the only thing where it's gonna
matter
right but on the other side it give you
incentive to jump in there and that's
literally why for me just the fact that
I know I can still get the 600 without
finishing the raid is kind of like I
feel kind of cheaply getting there
like I didn't rate that much him on d2
because I didn't have a good group for a
Leviathan I just didn't do it that often
especially in the others but I was
always able to hit max level but it was
like but I'm not really doing that end
game quote stuff I'm just kind of doing
the powerful gear path which is an
option and I understand that piece of it
and they've made the grind harder for
sure it definitely takes some time if
you're not rating but it's just one of
those pieces like if you saw somebody
who's level 30 or like damn they spend
some time in there they got all the
pieces they finally granted their butt
off I was twenty nine point nine forever
until my helm dropped so and no the eyes
like believe me I've been through that
grind so I don't know just one of those
pieces with the raid I and kind of the
in-game piece that I'm still probably
more on the elitist side but it'd just
be nice to see just that's a little more
incentive to for more people to get in
there
but as they did make this thing
basically one difficulty mode mm-hmm
what do you think there's not gonna be a
prestige or hard this is yes a big deal
this is a deck that's a big deal um
what's up advanced game even though he's
not addict but uh but you know here's to
do um I understand if someone is upset
about this now this one I can understand
I'm okay people you know some people
really like prestige wants to challenge
is you know put out there so to speak
right so um it's funny though because
you made some points that I actually
agree with in the sense that for the
people who want it that's not gonna be
there I get that they want an extra
challenge after a beat rating rate Riven
fine I get that valid argument but I
think for me because the way the raid
was constructed because it was such a
hard level of entry and then you as you
level up then you can get to the next
you can get to from Kali
so you know 560 Sheryl Chi or whatever
then to 580 whatever that you know the
ogre and so
I think the way it's structured it feels
like this Monument climb so that I don't
feel that I personally need a prestige
you know I'm saying and then here's the
other thing that we got to think about
with the raid layers coming because we
got what we got black armory coming
right we got that's December like dude
we're October right now there's still
content coming we still got festival
laws stuff like that I think what I
think is happening is that they don't
have the time to really set aside
between the just because of this new
schedule now where it's like instead of
the arm to content drops now it's the
three because gonna fall spring summer
right so I think because even even with
other layers didn't we get either in
spire late those prestige can you guys
hear me
yeah can hear you know like we got those
late so I don't hold on once I let you
do that I'm just finished the thing is I
I get it for the people who want
prestige and love that extra challenge
mm-hmm I can see them being upset I
think you know what I think I'm more
upset about then that no-one's talking
about no challenge mode don't
there's the rate challenge do they like
the claim they're pretty much the same
thing yeah for the callee you the
challenge mode was to kill all three
augers in the middle I mean they they
might not be as challenging as certain
ones but I feel like certain challenges
- oh pastor raids have been easy right
well I think they've kind of took it
away from being like a raiding or client
thing you have to do with your clan
mm-hmm yeah and the last point that I
will forgetting that we got to talk
about is that within defense of this
decision that they're doing now yes they
have those wishes now that now
apparently we're gonna read the 12 that
you can do things to make it harder or
whatever it is this Petra challenge
whatever 13th wishes brutal brutal I
don't know if I'm doing that so like
that's and you have to get that for the
ribbons man I'm like not one death in
the whole yeah would beat the for the
world's first already done that oh I
know yeah I was like yeah redeemed it
already yep is there any curated
specialist you know but they're damn
sure should be if there's not those
pieces where it's a really cool thing to
do it okay then make one piece of gear
just like make a he'd just say
guaranteed what it's a tier 10
masterwork just whatever it is a random
tier 10 masterwork from the raid just
drop from doing that like completely
flawless that's worth something a
feature I feel like if you do in that
hole right completely flawless no one's
dying
you deserve a thousand voices like I
really beat it before there's no way
you've ever beat it before because it's
not one of those things where if someone
dies you go back to that check more
someone dies you start the whole raid
over yeah yeah so what do you think I
think I know he jumped in you chomping
at the bit we have had you flashpoint in
a minute so what do you think about this
whole rate thing I think is the best
raid that bungees ever made wait last
time I talked to you you had taken King
above this AME I've gone spy I feel like
don't like Riven herself is cool her
mechanics is fun but I felt like the
first time seeing Oryx was better either
yeah
but like when it comes to actual
mechanics hmm I have to give it to the
last push because the only other one
that is you know was on point with some
of these Wallis's was go girl mmm what
is your favorite encounter sure oh gee
[Applause]
for kognito there what the vault is
pretty good too I like the vaults music
- really I haven't gotten it yet
let me tell you right now man I told
y'all the ohm I forgot the name of the
track but it's played during asha Roachy
and there's a there's a if you want to
know some what how this how the track
sounds the original track is in the
shadow Chi fight and in the escape a
Rubens heart fight but if you want to
hear very eh it's actually gambit gambit
has a variation of it when he's
you know you know when he starts to line
you up and he's like you know she vex is
gonna be the thing that's part of that
beauty if you've never heard of you guys
are not doing the race but continue
that's my job and I like I think the
thousand I think you know there's a huge
rumor going on right now when you beat
Riven and I returned the heart there's
like a bunch of chess that's in the
final room and there's like bunch of
speculation if the thousand of voice is
in one at least one of those chests
every time there's like 25 chests right
mm-hmm so like I just want to ask you
guys do you I don't think but geez
confirmed that do you think that's it I
feel like if they put 25 chests in there
it's for a reason one of those has that
and nine times out of ten no one's
getting one because there's nobody for
chest you know if only one has that
means you have a one out of twenty [ __ ]
it's I think I heard it was twenty four
but the way they did that is you have
six players and I guess if you have four
keys each you can actually open every
single chest and that was actually how
they opened one of those wishes mmm so
like from what I from what I gather I
think you are right I think they feel
like they've said it is probably one in
one of those every time so it's just
wrong yeah it just when it comes down to
it like you I heard you guys is a with
the shattered throne he I feel like the
reason that you're not gonna see
prestige anytime soon is because they're
not making these these events and
they're not doing the structure of
destiny where it's only like this week
you do this this next week you do that
it this one's looks like it's set up
okay these four or five weeks you do
this raid and maybe next the beginning
of next year will give you prestige I
don't think there's gonna be any
procedure right either five wait I think
I think then the when they actually
raise the light level that's when the
first stage is gonna happen
mmm but he thinking I mean the way I'm
reading this is the way the the raid is
built now feels like a heart rate anyway
these encounters are not easy for
somebody to jump in it's a very
mechanics heavy it's not just like you
could literally take stuff away with
this and then put a basically I would
say guided game friendly RAID mode in
there
when they if you were say okay say if
you did a guided or Cali for example say
there were only three symbols instead of
six like you could cut things out of all
of these fights still make them raved
feeling Oh keep that out of my rate oh
my god yeah I had to get over to you
because this is Lord raid this man lives
for the rape of our defeat the raid four
times right so collisions salute salute
the thing with him is this is his
premium extra' this is the reason you
know he's one of the remeber he quit
destiny to I was done when Leviathan and
then the foolishness was going on with
the community in the game at that point
he was in so to see him back in full
force in this level is a testament I
just didn't mind the Leviathan I felt
like it was like we it wasn't part of
the Destiny universe it was like a it
was like a what's where I'm looking for
it was like a show game that somewhere
you just pop in it he you know like
anything serious like it felt like it
wasn't part of the Lord like it was
literally just throwing in there and you
go there and the host is just messing
with you look it feels like low-key like
low-key is just up there messing with
you every inch that everything you do
and I like the most serious tone right
it's like you know right here we did the
last wish it is likely responsible for
what happened in the Forsaken or it when
you fought works the reason you fought
works is because it was directly a
response from what happened from the
taken King expand chant now is won by
you there's nothing with nothing yeah
it's just like okay we kill ball maybe
just it's like we're just sitting around
you know watching TV in the Bama love
big [ __ ] just appears out of nowhere
explanation no narrative no we get there
we still haven't even killed the owner
how yeah you know trust me we've gone on
and on about how we feel about that boy
oh yeah you know I just wanted to get I
want to get on this because I know it's
just important to him but yeah yeah I
mean I think you said it too I think
it's just one of those things that um
you know for me I don't care as much but
what do you really care like um
no prestige no like what's your final
verdict like what what's your whole
thing right now that they've announced
it's no prestige this is how they're
going with last wish the way the raid is
made I think it is as it should be
I think it's a very difficult raid very
mechanics heavy you have to know your
stuff you have to be on point the whole
time there is no like normal to hard and
hard is just cuz of like like the desk
the only thing I would probably say is
just because the tokens are annoying and
you can't clutch fights with that but
generally if the tokens were still out
you still have to be absolutely on top
of your stuff at certain points you got
to know your call-outs you got to make
sure you're right you miss one eye on
Riven I've watched the fight you miss
one you're tough like there's very very
little margin for error so I think the
difficulty is probably where it needs to
be and the fact that they put in that
wish to say hey try it without dying
ever I mean you want a challenge that
damn like let like team clarity you guys
are beast modes so I mean that's what to
me it doesn't bother me at all because
honestly the way they did prestige or
hard whatever they did for Leviathan
those challenges felt so arbitrary it's
like hey let me mix up what weapons you
can use and I don't think that got a lot
yeah what I you know what I meant to say
not the eater of world it inspires
challenges I don't necessarily care for
that forced loadout thing I meant like
taking the king challenges remember how
they used the encounters differently or
every hit all six orbs you have to trade
it turned it back and forth
right yeah those were interesting to
learn but then kind of once you did it
it was like okay sometimes it just felt
like say gold girl for example were you
all six had to hold it it literally just
got to the point where there were more
places to screw up but it was not really
something actually made the encounter it
didn't add something it literally just
was like all of you have to touch so
just like literally length in the fight
some were good some weren't I mean all
of them weren't perfect dado of course
had his thoughts on those we've all
heard that right um I don't I wouldn't
mind seeing challenges like that those
were kind of cool to throw it
occasionally be like hey and because it
gave you another loot chest as well so
that was kind of a nice piece to be like
hey what is the challenge mode or Kali
like the clan one say you
have to summon the ogres and that gives
you something else to work on for the
raid so I mean I wouldn't mind seeing
those four needing another difficulty I
don't think so
challenges i I could see that as being a
cool addition but I don't think it needs
another difficulty it's already a pain
to the bus I think you about to say
something before using one I think the
reason that when I've seen one any time
soon is because this raid light the
light level to do this raid was
significantly higher than the other one
and they can't go any higher at the
moment because it's pretty much straight
at max lighting so - I completely agree
with you and I think because of the
structure and the fact that if they wait
and try to extend an artificial light
level for a prestige mode with the
timing of black armory right because
this would be real like
what's the name of this expansion for
say like France where you been not
necessary
forsaken right has so much more content
than the average destiny expansion right
yeah the Dreaming cities doing something
I just think in the timeline they
probably made a decision and said hey
we're gonna make it hard there won't be
a prestige there'll be a three week
cycle there's still more secrets
remember there's still stuff in the
database out the unknown player and all
these guys there's still stuff that we
haven't seen and haven't gotten yet
right so you're gonna time lock those
things then roll these events out
festival laws blah blah blah and then
boom here comes black armory it comes
machine guns the secret crest what's
going on there where's this area raid
lair
again I think that's probably the real
reason that's why my gut says I think I
mean I have to leave here in a second
but I think when it comes to what I
think Destiny's a good spark I like the
way they're going I'm actually about to
release a video probably tomorrow on
whether or not this and he's too hard I
think when it comes down to it I think
what they weren't trying to go this
direction they had a player base that
wasn't he on the top 50 loved Xbox at
the end of the day the people that are
going to keep this game alive are the
people that the hardcore the the people
that wanna challenge
the people I do think there are a couple
things that needed to be fixed I think
it's ridiculous that you play for 40
plus hours not forsaken in you can't
participate in the raid day one I think
that and I don't think that's
necessarily though anything to do with
your unfriend site I see he's on France
no it's not that like if I put 40 plus
hours into a game I feel like I should
be part of the going in but I don't
think that's the game being hard I think
that's the loop system being stupid but
I think that I need whatever reason
there's no reason why I should have to
get 25 plus kinetic weapons in a row
yeah that day that just comes down to
yeah orangy of what's needed to actually
bump you anything like you said you'll
get the same helmet you get the same gun
with me a week
having a skill base not a log base they
need I do something because and it's
like I said in my video a lot of things
people don't realize is is you actually
have a lot more opportunities with
deaths of whatever second than you do
love IDEs and you have one engrams you
the only thing that I would say that a
lot of people are leveling up quicker
Leviathan is because the exotic to
operate solo yeah
in Leviathan you get you get an exotic
drop rate that's like twenty five-plus
right and remember we were farming
public events in the Leviathan era just
for light remember so that's a huge
thing but now I you saying bro I mean it
that's up for the debate you know the
whole orangey to get to max light and
how you know you just can be completely
unlucky in you because saying grenade
launcher like 50 times
hello HJ you know they have said that
you know there's some minor tweaks that
we need no no I understand people you
know I get the reason they went the
direction they went the raid and you
know I've told Laura Cognito I agree
with it but at the same time like if Ike
if I think I probably put more than
forty hours I know like this game like
eight nine hours for two weeks as a
friend said and I should be able to do
that raid a war but let me ask you this
question is my only counting
is it because you can't do the rain or
is it because you can't do the raid weak
wood because you can do the raid it's
just that you weren't lucky enough and
get the perfect rocks and everything to
do it and and I feel like that's my
issue with it is because it was blocked
base it wasn't skill base that I kept
getting like I literally felt like the
my powerful Engram all of the week right
before the rate was kinetic weapons
every single ignorant with a kinetic way
you let you in a nice tweak to thee and
I feel like if some little minor tweak
like that I mean let's be real her you
know this race isn't hard this raid was
hard based off light I'm in the five 90s
and we placed through this in 40 minutes
now mmm shoutout to TF Chronos well I
was gonna say if people were as high
going into into this the struggle on
that first day would not have been what
it was if you were there in four hours
I guarantee but I think that's what made
it so special right it's okay so then
you just counted your own point I didn't
say that I didn't I didn't agree with it
I did I literally said I agree with the
direction they went to but I feel like
the the the drop system should be tweet
the drop are in geez what you talk about
for I don't mind the right I don't mind
what level light the rate is I was yeah
that's different yeah yeah both agree
his point is what E is what TF Chronos
in your chat is saying saying that yeah
I've got over 40 hours in only and only
525 do the duplicates he said I don't
wanna grind I just wish to lose system
wasn't as stupid as it is okay so here's
a counter to that from a different game
this contribution world of course just a
reference and that's kind of one is
somebody dedicated like you addict I
know you'll kind of understand there are
certain permissions so you get to max
level but you have to basically level up
light it's a similar thing but you just
kind of a different piece of your level
there are different tiers of say
dungeons that you would go through and
say there's our heroic dungeon I go
through it and the only way I'm gonna
complete my set and kind of get my level
up to kind of that next piece is I have
to complete this set of gear I can run
the same thing and I only will get my
helm off of one boss and I can go
through that thing ten times not get
my drop and then I get nothing there's a
point where you can you can get nothing
or you guys can get duplicates in
certain spots and they kind of have some
random rules and something to get but if
I'm literally going in there and the
only thing drops literally for a
completely different class of character
or something I can not use and I might
drop only comes from one boss that gets
the whole different level of hardness
that's not hard
well I was like it's kind of that's why
I was saying I'd like another game maybe
maybe the concept is that game needs to
change they [ __ ] too for a lot of
evolution I mean it absolutely has but
still in turn you just said like the the
specialness of this raid on day one is
because people were not as high if the
arm was fixed then everybody and then
all the duplicates then it would have
been done in three or four hours so it's
like how do you you can't have it both
ways that's the point that's what I see
too because it's like if we all get
there we're gonna play stuff look I'm
not gonna say here I'm not going to
condone Bungie let me get 15 to 20
kinetic weapons in a row I'm just not
going to it's not gonna happen that's
your opinion I'm not you you are you are
justified to have that opinion you know
I understand that thing do you have a
fix to say hey you don't want 20 kinetic
weapons I can understand that but how do
you still make the raid than as special
as it was all I'm saying is I should get
the same the same slot almost I like
literally can I ask you a question we
cannot like let me ask you a question to
counter their 590 it hasn't been too bad
because I probably put 90 hours in the
game I'm sorry that you ain't been
grindin right oh my god now it's a grad
fit grind blame you let me ask you this
question real quick cuz I know you gotta
go um how many Forsaken exotics do you
have none really not not one weed either
every time I get in it's always a year
one and explained to me how you do a
quest exotic for Ace of Spades then it
could be a drop
as we talked about earlier okay I doing
that because on the flip side ebon sees
have you don't use got like I've gotten
three of those okay so I was just very
curious yet because I want to know if
you got because so basically this is
just an orangey debate that's all it's a
completely different thing we I think we
all agree the raid was fantastic we all
agree the difficulty coming in we were
fine with just that point of contention
is just whether they need to fix the RNG
system number one issue I have to leave
is it's not necessarily on what level
was what anything would it was it was
the fact that the people that got to do
the Rey day one they had better luck
where they Pro or they farm prime
Ingram's had to do a grind it's because
they literally had a better shot at our
engine than anyone else like Gaines ran
on one but it doesn't make sense that
you know I'm not gonna even have this
argument the Lord cometh dude I had to
get her because I know this is it's a
bit yeah good luck of Akko now bro we
will talk and I will see you in the
realm on Sunday later bro yeah I had to
bring it because I do this is gonna come
it's it represents the France I and I
and I get it you know I understand the
frustration you know how mean you feel
about it II you know so um I don't know
it's one of those like I mean Sean
Finegan on party oh I loved he destroyed
that topic but he absolutely did he's
like he wasn't even there but it's like
like okay so you weren't quite there on
day one so this maybe isn't your raid
for a first time it doesn't mean you
have to be like just because you put in
certain amount of time mm-hmm that is
literally part of luck and that's why I
was like world is a reference because
it's a similar type of game we have
glasses we have our mg we have drops we
have all that crap is in there and then
you get to a point of okay so and that's
what I was saying I would go through
certain things like when you run world
of warcraft raids like the main boss
that you kill
you're only gonna have a few drops
there's 40 people in a raid guess what
the top people get those drops you
literally raved for like two months and
not get a damn thing name call so I mean
there's difference of references I
understand we're not playing world or a
cough good lord
lady if you're done listen attic is a
very passionate writer it's always good
to get have it both ways
yes like yeah you know what we had back
and have the orange Maxx one has to give
see you're talking big picture and
that's where ultimately you win the
argument because at the end of the day
if you fix the loop right to not give
duplicate kinetics and duplicate of
whatever you don't need and then you get
what you need with a higher percentage
come raid a you're gonna be five eight
if you blaze right hey orange EB correct
then literally make the max seven
hundred figure out like the calculation
of okay the raid comes out in ten days
what is the like the person who like no
life's this thing what is the max that
they can potentially be if you're
getting your orangey you know with a
decently better calculator orangey okay
say they get to six hundred you start it
there and then that's where you start
the thing I mean you can adjust it
accordingly if you want to feel better
about your drops
but then in turn to still make the
difficulty and especially in us you just
literally move the chain farther out his
fix
like we said will affect that lovefest
he has for the difficulty being hard he
can't he doesn't in 40 minutes because
he's five ninety so then the challenge
isn't as much there it's not let first
day should be a challenge and then also
the fact okay gaming addict if you're
still sitting in chat let me know on the
other side do you think you should be
able to get to 600 without doing the
raid now if you answer I'll be kind of
curious what you say on that one because
I've I beat the rate no I haven't I'm
not high enough that's the point I've
played a buttload of time but I've also
spent some time like helping out friends
and things like that so I haven't
officially gone as hardcore but I'm just
saying I'm not saying it's an easy rate
I'm not saying it's something that you
just should be able to do but if it
didn't happen for you in the week one it
looks like a real issue is dudes want to
do it the first week that's all this is
everyone wants to be part of their team
and unfortunately you gotta be lucky and
then the second thing is if we have the
fix right well you have our ingenue or
you're getting these traps we have a
similar situation to the launch of d2
which is when you everyone's at Max and
is really not as much of a challenge as
this was what made this great because of
the challenge was the fact that so few
got to do it so that's why it was
popularized when people were watching
world's first and all this stuff it does
have a lot to do it luck this is a
Loutre shooter that's how many hours
people put in what it is and they can
tweak they can make tweaks they said
they're gonna make tweaks to exotics as
far as the exotic loophole they said
they're gonna make tweaks to certain
things there will be some tweaks but at
the end of the day like my boy deaf
senior say there's gonna be the haves
it's gonna be the have-nots at just how
orange is I don't see how we fix it but
we beat this thing to death
but I had to get that in there that was
a photo debate action on well flashpoint
uh yeah lost and found yeah I know
you're the screen sharing guide sorry
about that but Festival Lost is coming
back it will go on October 16th they
don't say how long it's gonna last what
does it usually like two to three weeks
someone there something like that so
they say a celebration of lost heroes a
new challenge to tackle which I'm not
entirely sure but that'll be includes a
costume party you're all invited and it
ends with a quest to solve a murder
honestly what do you what do you think
like sounds well no ovale for one my
better course would be who died yeah but
the other pieces
do you think of all the festival loss to
be seen as forsaken has already kind of
kicked the doors off everything else you
think this is gonna be think it'll be
good
it's listen I already like the whole
foolishness of what this sounds like we
get it it's a costume party and we have
to solve a but it's literally a whodunit
in destiny
so no fun to the game looked with our
Tara it sounds already better than
festival of the cost last year the key
is gonna be how much these things going
cause if they're gonna cost at all
because we know this event in particular
has had a very interesting history right
so we'll see how it shakes but I am very
intrigued by that sense it's yeah it's
it's I mean it gives you something to
look forward to and you know we've had
the raid we've had the three-week cycle
we have the shattered throne which will
actually come back on this week as well
so in case you don't have enough stuff
to do in a week BAM there's another one
but this should probably at least go on
for a couple of weeks so you might do
shattered throne first week work a
little more on festival the next week
two or three weeks you have some time
back and forth but the masks coming back
are cool I kind of wonder how they're
doing the mask and this is where they
desperately desperately need a transmog
system all year badly yeah mm-hmm big
time like because I mean if I get a mask
of aldrin or if I get one of the
meatball which you know is gonna be in
there
but I still want to keep my light level
higher kind of messes with it so that's
the whole point of like some of those
cosmetic ridiculousness --is they don't
have a light level to them you usually
probably won't have rolls so they're
literally just gonna take away from your
light level so the fact of wearing them
all the time as light matters and a lot
of things it kind of takes away from the
fun so give me some transmog please
Khaleesi yeah I agree it sounds cool
like a quest involved with the murder a
challenge to it costume party a lot of
good things in there this is good it's a
testing for to Daddy dad you can use the
back room if so far like Steve and Scott
have been on their money from bungee
like so far they've been they've been
nailing this
and I don't know whoever's working on
what comes in next September but man
that's a hell of a bar to hit about one
before but yeah it's like seriously they
they learn their list and when they got
really bashed last time and they
definitely made improvements last year
and honestly with this one I just hope
they keep pushing it right yeah yeah so
that's that's dead but it's good that
it's coming around and they look like
they're gonna try to do something cool
so then that's it and it looks like it
was like player support yeah cover a
couple things explained about nightfall
rings just kind of how that works and
the whole way of going through Savalas
system which is honestly it's kind of
cool it actually done a couple of the
hundred thousand point nightfalls now
just getting a couple for instant be
like okay works we gonna try for it and
if you got a decent multiplier and some
mods on there it's cool so the higher
you get just bigger modification to your
light levels gonna make it easier so I
like that that'll be kind of a thing
they've got some known issues out there
but you know malfeasance claims yeah
that's all passion notes if you guys
need to see the the needy grease that
you guys can jump in as well couple
videos like right here yes the baby
Petra's no so when you get down to the
first movie of the week Petra's to run
flawless all the strength with which
gigs and clad and all them so I was like
it already
just absolutely killing it so guys I
think if Kozma our Dylan said he was out
of town but he's back to the grind and I
think we are too like him so so much to
do max so I mean overall for a
difficulty I think we kind of I like
where it's at and it doesn't bother
bother to me that there's a prestige but
I do think challenges would be kind of a
cool thing to see it alive maybe giving
some legs down the road maybe throw a
challenge maybe throw some challenges in
with some of the expansion stuff like
that might be a cool I think no I don't
you I think just to double down on it I
think I think the reason why I am so
forgiving with them not having a chasm
oh let's keep it rare this rate is so
well done
oh this rate is so well done it is so
regardless of how you feel about the
light starting or whatever that was like
you we have to admit these encounters
are great the narrative is great post
Riven is fantastic dream in cities
fantastic
chatted oh so it's like this whole feel
good thing about this content that we
like look you gave us a full course we
thought we were gonna get you know a
nice little lunch you know great dinner
we got some dessert afterwards so it's
like can we really get upset and be like
hey I forgot that extra you know that I
forgot that I screaming normally
sometimes used to give I really can't
not with this one you know I'm saying
but you know for those who you know say
hey I really miss I wanted that you know
I get that but um I think I think the
reason why I'm okay with it is just man
this is really really good content
really good and on so many levels and I
just I'm dying to see like you said you
know with it's such a tough act of
whoever's the team be behind following
you know say this expansion I feel sorry
for the black armory team already
oh man that one's yeah that alone is
gonna be like oh this is good how do you
follow the team that literally saved
destiny - yeah I mean I'm hoping it's on
a similar track hey if the rate ler
sticks with at least the Dreaming city
it's already a good step cuz we're still
within the lower so with that connection
so here all seized area I was like if
they throw it in somewhere else like now
what would be cool
mmm-hmm I wonder if they'll ever do a
raid lair somehow attached to tangled
short mmm
that would be but I think that could be
another piece that's like you know not
quite a deviation like a complete
oddball connection apartment from the
story odd but I think it could I think
they probably got something they could
do with that would be kind of cool to
see more with that area as well like the
Dreaming city and then maybe the thing
back on the tangled Shore kind of goes
back to some other connection or
something come back and spring or summer
so that'd be kind of interesting to see
but yeah when it comes to late
yeah the armor is gonna be tough because
for one we definitely need to see
weapons but they are bringing machine
guns to the table so there's gonna
some discussion about that but my big
one is these are going to be smaller
pieces they know they're not gonna be
the full story not a full raid but man
when it comes to next September that bar
is off the charts yeah oh yeah it's
gonna be this ridiculous man absolutely
yeah don't don't envy the devs you guys
have some work you've done awesome but
literally now you can't stop running at
a full sprint so good luck try and sleep
in there and keep your sanity but yeah
not quite as long as the other week but
still close to two hours I know some
people be waiting a little longer than
they want for some of these changes
whether it's two weeks or a month for
some of these they are coming they're
working on it but you can only
apparently do something so quickly
some things go parently some things
don't so if you like destiny well with
what you got and if you're not loving
what you're doing just mix it up let me
try different try you know the raid wait
for the shattered throne work on your
light level hit your powerful gear and
honestly if you need a little break and
go play some color day it'll be waiting
for you when it gets back exactly
there's some forza horizon out there
some great games right now man a lot of
stuff a lot of stuffs Asus Creed stuff
for me you know saying like I said you
heard of how long Assassin's Creed is I
did hear exactly it's just too much it's
it's so much like I said my problem is
when destiny is good I just don't want
to stop playing destiny I just might
know I'll lose one of my friends to
black out for a while okay looks good
now it looks good I did get to play that
you've got Red Dead coming at the end of
the month which is just like gonna suck
people's lives away and just all of that
alone on top of everything else so yeah
lots of stuff coming in the future but
if you're having fun a destiny just keep
having fun find the parts that you enjoy
and spend some time in them and look
forward to the next week of rotations
but yeah biggest thing guys just stay
tuned or channels you got the awesome
iron Lords podcast coming up on Sunday
as he says the Lord's Day I'll let you
take care of your intro for that no
doubt yeah every Sunday the Lord's Day
or the inner circle Network
we'll go live at 11 a.m. Eastern
Standard Time we will have l-boogie who
is in the chat today she will be in the
realm of the Lord's when we talk to me
male from the female perspective of
course her whole movement that she's got
going on as well as the stream team
stuff cuz l-boogie is part of the stream
team I'm a pocke stream team we've got
some fun stuff cooking up with that so
it's gonna be good to get a perspective
and just talk gaming
she knows her game and let me tell you
she knows her destiny because uh fun fun
quick story Oh like I was playing this
week and I don't have a lot of time and
then you know I got home and I was like
it's one of those days I'm like I know I
need to go to bed I was gonna sneak up
as offline so nobody can see me they're
like a bug that's gonna come and then go
to bed and I jump in and I'm like
playing with it and I'm literally
carrying his team I like literally these
guys are like potatoes like these
blueberries are not doing their job so
I'm sitting in I'm in a gunfight and I
see el buggies they come up or the
opposite team got a couple of is it like
I cut her a couple of times do it right
now bill I'll do my pixels cameras what
I was and then I should be a party chat
I don't like oh so yeah they're team one
oh she had a squad a day one I know I'm
actually out but I led on the losing
squad it was a close one but it was a
shelter we will have her in the realm of
the Lord's we got that going on
obviously um with the armor podcast
YouTube channel please subscribe to that
we're really trying to build that we
have a lot of original content there we
go to shows we do on packs III a lot of
the big events also combat tour for the
King if you like boxing and of course
flashpoint with my man the box of
destiny don't know how to take that one
but the complement the men that are
still in chat out there in the
kind of one of those tidbits before I
wrap up my in long gorgeous sometimes
gets the better of me as you guys can
tell flashpoint is usually not flashy
it's you know uh it may be shiny but not
quick so I was on a raid guide for kind
of more of a solo casual encounter type
practice the damn thing for Cali ended
up being about half an hour so honestly
my curiosity guys would you have any
interest in me posting that on my
youtube channel or is that like you're
like that's way too long I'm gonna go
watch that oh so I'm literally just
curious if you guys think that's worth
me putting up I've got most of it done
already so I may just throw it up there
anyway and see what happens but I'm just
as you guys are live in chat let me know
your thoughts and see if that's
something that you guys would like to
see because I set it up as like a not a
solo cally but kind of a way basically
so I set it up as if you're gonna go in
and say you've never done the last was
raid but you want to be able to go into
Kali and actually feel like you know
what you're doing
I basically explained that you can go in
and practice everything that you'll need
to do to handle your plate on your own
see what the damage cycle looks like and
see all of that so you can literally go
in and practice the first fight on your
own and know that you can handle your
plate you can handle the night and you
can handle your piece of the fight and
then honestly if you get to then when
you get to actually join a team you'll
have that first fight pretty much unlock
so it is a longer video for sure I tried
to give you guys pretty much everything
I could obviously yeah I'll get that one
up there just you guys today as I said
it's about it's about 30 minutes so is
saying do it all right well I'll throw
it up there see what the see what the
feedback is I'm probably gonna get half
the comments that are like I'm not yeah
that's thank you death singer but yeah I
respectfully not quite I was like I'll
throw it up there and see I'm sure half
of its gonna be like cool I'd love to
see that any other people like you talk
too long and I'm gonna be like yeah I'm
gonna see that coming so all you guys
know where to find us
for me it's about us everywhere twitch
Twitter which you some of you guys are
on right now and then YouTube
shout out to my insane whisper video
that kind of exploded my channel
fifteen thousand subs now I don't even
know what I was last last last point but
just broke fifteen thousand yesterday I
was literally like watching it tick up
like 14 996 997 and there was at $14.99
for like half an hour and I was like ah
just like wait and then finally it
ticked over but I was just like is it
actually like stuck so that's been kind
of for me literally in probably two and
a half three weeks maybe my channel has
almost doubled so shout outs all you
guys new old long timers thank you guys
very very very much it's been awesome
and honestly it's just like fun stuff
that we get to do like this our love for
destiny here but you guys support iron
Lords podcast I was listening to a shout
out to a couple weeks ago zat Louis
who's the guy you know I'm talking about
which guy from Mexico all Louis yeah you
know he was talking about his destiny
point I was like oh there we go a little
bit 11 there too so that was really
really cool very good one last thing
with IOP I forgot um please this is
definitely one not to miss besides the
amazing l-boogie we are gonna have a big
special announcement on this Sunday at
the animals podcast so again if you can
if you make it live 11:00 a.m. Eastern
but be sure to make it if you miss it
live we're gonna be actually gonna edit
and put it on the iron law podcast
channel a little quicker now we're gonna
be getting that up instead of waiting a
week before you get the episode we can
wait only like a day so you're gonna get
it on the initial source life and also
when I'm a public don't miss this one
we've got a big announcement and
especially in your chat a shout out hi
certified it's up the he it's gonna be
something he'd like that he requested
for a long time from the iron law
podcast so hopefully you guys tune in
for that it's a nice enough yeah check
them out check out the man with the best
intros in the business it'll be awesome
it's gonna be the abundances Lord now
that's like I'll just take the honorary
title you guys but yeah it's like we're
pretty much wrapping it up guys so thank
you chats been awesome like I know more
subs brings a few more people to the
party so spread the word if you like
playing destiny or just be in that gamer
in general and it'll shout out like
sometimes
to King in the iron Lords podcast there
are some points or like hey he's got his
combat and stuff like that and he's got
some moments of just absolute crazy but
there are moments where it just brings
it down to earth and I just wanted to
kind of wrap on this one for you guys
cuz I just got done catching up on a
couple iron Lords podcast we're all
gamers we love gaming or passionate so I
just want to say thank you all for being
awesome gamers awesome people out in
this world but is going on and just
thank you guys
be decent humans have fun gaming don't
be a turd out in the world and just like
have fun enjoy the games and if you're
not enjoying it find something to have
fun for so thank you guys that will wrap
it for october fifth and it's been
amazing yes sir
yep see you guys soon go check ILP in a
couple days peace